the liberal media thinks you're just
plain too dumb to understand how great
the Biden economy is 78% of Voters
that's almost 80% Herold says Biden eom
Biden economics is a certified crap
sandwich numbers like that causing
Publications like the Atlantic to ask
why Americans hate a good economy
blaming the media loving bad news among
the reasons NBC thinks it's a branding
issue yeah Biden omics has really been
kind of a negative become a negative
word especially among Democrats cuz it's
not working I was texting with some
members of democratic members of
Congress last night these members said
that it is just not looking good for
President Biden politically out there
they have a lot of work to do to once
again like I said try to get get credit
for the successes that he's had over the
past two
years and President Biden boasting about
how you should be thanking him this
Thanksgiving well this past week as
Americans gathered around their own
kitchen tables for Thanksgiving dinner
that was our goal to give them a little
more breathing room from Turkey to air
travel to tank of gas cost went
down oh well thank you for that Harold
in The Green Room you said you were so
disgusted by him you were thinking of
challenging him for the candidacy for
presidency YY Harold I got to go to the
tape on that one but I mean like blaming
blaming the American for being upset
about a bad economy that's pretty low
even for a Democrat look I I think the
line of people who told tried to tell
voters you're doing better than you
think you are who were in politics or
who are at home is it's a big list of
them uh this is a weird economy though
you think about it inflation is trending
down Unemployment uh has remained uh
muted meaning it's it's lower than than
you would think more people are working
job more more than one job which gives
people inks and more and more people are
living paid pay check the paycheck the
wealth Gap continues continues to grow
he's right gas prices were down U but if
we are where we are six months from
today exactly where we are today they
will the Biden White House will be in
trouble because the numbers it's hard to
turn around numbers on the economy but
if things continue to improve I don't
agree with the Atlantic piece I think
you I think the young the young woman
from MSNBC was talking about the from
The Washington Post uh the title bomic
is probably going to have to change
they're going to have to come up with
something different as we get into the
election season next year but the next
several months if things improve they'll
have a better argument but you have to
be careful you cannot tell the American
people who are working two jobs and
three jobs that they're doing better uh
if they don't believe they're doing
better and expect to win that's a number
you can't overcome even though we have
electoral data the last two or three
weeks ago Democrats fared well in those
elections if you make this Eon if you
make this election about the economy and
people don't feel right about it you're
not going to win no matter how much the
Atlantic magazine and others say that
people should be feeling well I love how
the media is blaming the
media it's like suicide you think
they'll all die you know that wouldn't
that be interesting you know what when
they say this when they actually go out
and say everything is really okay they
do nothing but hurt their re-election
chances because people don't believe it
it's what they feel you know and it's
it's it's it's clear that they're living
in a bubble whether it's Karine
jeanpierre or Joe Biden or his son
Hunter who I think is living with him I
know naam naami lived with him for a
while when she was getting married I
mean and they get their food their car
their insurance everything is paid for
by the government but I think that the
biggest concern is that there was an NBC
poll that only 19% of Americans feel
confident that their children's
generation would be better off 19%
thinks my kids will do at least as good
or better than me but what is amazing is
if do you remember last week when we had
the illegals or maybe it was the week
before they were going to move into
Brooklyn and the illegals said I'd
rather go home this is not the American
dream even the illegals are fed up with
it by nomics why you looking at
me Dan uh the judge mentions that maybe
it's that high status professionals can
absorb higher costs so it's not that big
a deal for them and they get to work
from home right they only have to work
one job I think it's interesting too
that they don't they don't seem to
remember how did Bill Clinton win what
did he say oh yeah I feel your pain Joe
Biden constant refrain is your pain is
fake yeah and that try to if you try to
tell a woman that how she's feeling
trust that doesn't work right guys we
all know that uh the other thing is um
it costs $20 more for every $100 than it
did before okay missed it I'm sure it
was really good anyway gas prices um
might be down a little bit but food
prices continue and home prices shelter
it's taking up about 50% of somebody's
budget when it should be around 30% used
cars
car insurance every they people feel
like they are being nickel and dime to
death and there's no like Forward
Thinking so Joe Biden is running for
president he wants to run again and he's
telling you everything's great
everything's fine so then why would you
if you don't like him he's given you
nothing to reach for like what do they
want to do to help the economy in the
future they just think that the
inflation reduction act that didn't
actually reduce inflation is going to
work I it doesn't make sense it doesn't
you know Jesse the uh hair American hair
and grooming Institute say that hair gel
and moose has skyrocketed by 45% how
have you been able to cope with this
where's the beef it's up
30% got milk that's up 20% poultry
that's chicken thank you that's up 30%
Lumber that's a nice way of saying wood
that's up 25% Iron and Steel 50% you're
talking about getting nickel and dimed
nickels up
Dana rubber is up 25% use those for car
tires cotton which is Greg's suits made
out of 20% coffee's up 40% so oil back
in the day $37 a barrel now $75 a barrel
so everyone's wondering why things are
expensive your house your appliances
rental costs College tuition
everything's expensive and then they're
telling you it's not that expensive so
they're insulting your pocketbook and
your integrity it's not work bomic and
I'm looking at you yeah in your face huh
maybe go on a bridge and
protest it's for the record the last
time people voted we
won well according to the uh well never
mind up next hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else